[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and it feels like
we've been waiting forever
for a look at the turtles uh not my best
joke yeah i'll admit
but new rock stars and screen crush
haven't uploaded their videos yet
so you're stuck with me for now now in
this we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to know about the
new marvel movie
the trailer itself and certain leaks
about the film's story
its director chloe zhao has just won the
oscar for bets director
and it's clear that this movie is going
to be something different
if you love the video 3000 then please
click the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our eternals
trailer breakdown okay so this game
attached to a video by marvel
that showed their past movies as well as
what was coming down the line
not only did it showcase some brand new
and unseen footage from black widow
but it also contains several new scenes
from shang chi
this included him using a knife against
death dealer in a moment that was very
reminiscent of bucky fighting against
captain america
they announced that black panther ii
will have the subtitle wakanda forever
and be out on july 8 2022 there was also
an announcement of the marvels coming
november 11
2022 which i'm guessing stars captain
marvel
and ms marvel not 100 on that though so
if you know different yeah
drop a comment below now before diving
into the eternals trailer
i feel like we need to talk about the
characters in the film and who the
eternals themselves are
up top you should know that the eternals
are well eternal in their lifespan
and this film itself is set to take
place both in present day
and thousands of years before tony stark
under the infamous words
i am iron man so expect to see a lot of
prequel elements
as well as discussions of the celestials
who have been hinted at in films such as
guardians of the galaxy
in the movie we will apparently watch
the origins of the eternals
and how they ended up on earth which is
where they attempted to blend in with
society now according to leaks on the
movie we will open with a flashback to
the past
in which we learn that the celestials
created the deviants in order to hunt
down predators who posed a threat to
newly evolving life
however the deviants grew a bloodlust
from doing this and ended up stamping
out life before it could rise up
thanos himself is actually a deviant and
this idea of genocide being laced
throughout his ancestors ideology
does explain why he wanted to destroy
all life in the universe
instead of just doubling the resources
now after realizing that they'd made a
monster
the celestials decided to counter this
by creating the eternals
who would defend against their
destruction throughout the galaxy
up top is the leader of the group icarus
played by richard madden
he's basically a superman and along with
being bulletproof he can fly
throw things really far because he's
super strong and he also has the ability
to fire cosmic blasts from his eyes we
also know that gemma chan is going to be
playing a big part in the film too
and she will be stepping into the shoes
of cersei who has the ability to
manipulate mata on a molecular level
though chan has already played minerva
and captain marvel like michelle yo
she's getting another shot
and will likely be sticking as this
character going forward
and that's because cersei is actually in
love with the black knight
played by kit harrington if you know
nothing jon snow
about him and he's basically your
sword-wielding medieval knight type
character
that will be using it to stab deviants
instead of dany
next up is thiena played by angelina
jolie
born in olympia during ancient greece
dina was picked by zeus to be the
representative of his daughter athena
if you played any of the god of war
games or are well versed in greek
mythology
then you may recognize her name and it's
now be confirmed that russell crowe is
also playing the king of the gods
so expect some more callbacks to these
myths and legends
dina has fought in several wars over the
centuries and is able to form
any weapon out of cosmic energy we see
her wielding one of these in the first
look
which appears to be a sword glowing with
the light next up is kumal nanjiani
who is playing kingo whereas the rest of
the group have kept a low profile over
the years
kingo has become a bollywood star so
that his other abilities get overlooked
in the trailer we can see a man standing
beside him with a camera
and what looks to be a film set in the
background i get a lot of johnny cage
vibes from this
and it appears that he's on location
shooting things you also have salma
hayek as ajak
who is the healer of the group and she
can basically channel cosmic energy in
order to provide
extra added life force to anyone she
chooses to
ajax can also telepathically communicate
with the celestials
and thus i think she will be used in
some form to reach out to them
in the movie god damn that picture i
swear i didn't pick that on purpose
that's from google that one now we see
her in the first shot of the trailer
riding horseback
and it's important to know that the
eternals actually split up during their
time on earth
this is what i believe the next shot of
them on the beaches they were unable to
agree on a lot of things
and ended up going their separate ways
before coming together
which is likely the shot that follows on
from that you can catch cersei at a
similar location at one point
making me believe that she has come here
to talk things out with ajak
we also have bry and tyree henry as
fastos who is the inventor of the
eternals
marvel have said that he's going to be
the first gay superhero in the mcu
and that he will be opening the door for
more inclusive characters to come into
the franchise
over the millennia he has worked in the
shadows helping humanity to grow
technologically
and he's got his fingers in more things
than tony stark next up is lauren
ridloff as muchari
who has superhuman speed and can be seen
showing this off in the trailer
makari is also deaf so it's going to be
interesting to see
how they handle this in the movie
donnelly is playing gilgamesh who's a
massive hulk of a man
that can surround himself in an
exoskeleton of cosmic energy
and there's also leah mchugh as sprite
seems like a young child on the surface
but she like the rest of the group is
thousands of years old
she's trapped in this form but wiser
than she looks and is capable of
projecting lifelike illusions
lastly out of the main cast of
characters is druid played by
barry kyowin whose name are always
butcher so apologies and advance
he's a psychic that can manipulate the
minds of others and initially he starts
off as one of the good guys
that wants what's best for humanity
however this leads to him controlling
them
and taking away their free will which is
sort of similar to what scarlet witch
did in one division
in the trailer we catch a shot of the
group at a village and
in the background you can see what looks
to be people all standing in a row
looking at the characters according to
the leaks when the group go to reunite
they visit a village that he has taken
over and here they find that he's mind
controlling everyone in order to stop
any potential conflict
i have my theories that he's gonna end
up being the big bad in the movie but of
course
let me know if you disagree as it could
really go anyway
now as for the trailer itself you know
it's it's very short and sweet and i'm
going to be honest and say that
of everything on the face for slate the
eternals are probably the people that i
know least about in general when it
comes to the cosmic side of marvel i
just find the overpowered superheroes
slightly uninteresting
and in the case of captain marvel i just
think they're almost too perfect to
fully relate to
marvel is great when it's doing
grounding characters that have been
blessed with incredible gifts
but at this point i also know that kevin
feige here we trust him
and i'm sure they can knock it out of
the park with whatever they touch
now though i've rattled off a lot of
negatives there i do think that they
have the opportunity to really flash out
the history and law of the mcu here
which i think will be fascinating
however it also depends on how long they
stay in the past
and i actually hope we properly explore
it without it just being a prologue
so we can see things like the rise of
thanos so little that we know about the
history of the universe and the
celestials are fascinating creatures
that pretty much shape the galaxy to be
the way that it is
so lots of things to explore and i know
i've criticized them for perhaps being
too
godly but do you think marvel will be
able to give these characters something
that people will find
some common ground with cersei in the
trailer says they're the ones who
changed everything
and this is clearly hinted with sadness
so they can provide an interesting
aspect and character study hopefully
i'm just a bit unfamiliar with the best
stories by them yeah and because of this
i'm unsure on how things will be handled
and so on
i don't know how they're going to
integrate into the universe and excuse
me yeah for making
the the worst breakdown ever that being
said though the film does look
interesting and
it's not like we're not going to see it
the director is also of course coming
off the back of an oscar win
so you can bet there are a lot of eyes
on this project
the cast is also incredible too and
arguably one of the best ensembles that
marvel have put together
so yeah i am excited for it yeah sorry
for being a negative nancy there
and it was a really great trailer
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know
as to thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the first look the winners
of last month's competition are on
screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers you want someone
else to watch them make sure you check
out our breakdown of invincible episode
8 which will be linked on screen right
now
we went over the finale from top to
bottom and talked about all the things
you need to know
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you have any questions out of the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace